.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Jusqu'à aujourd'hui, sept
autobus électriques seulement
étaient en opération à Montréal,
desservant depuis 4 ans la ligne
Monk entre le centre-ville et la
station Angrignon, dans l'ouest.
Leur autonomie est très limitée
et ils doivent être rechargés
après chaque parcours.
Cette façon de faire sera
bientôt révolue.
La Société de transport de
Montréal vient d'acquérir une
trentaine d'autobus électriques
dernier cri. Ils sont testés
à partir d'ici, dans l'immense
Centre dt Stinson,
de l'arrondissement St-Laurent.
- Ils ont servi dans la rue pour
noss test ingénierie, mais pas
pour des tests clientèle.
- Pascal Renaud dirige le projet
d'électrification pour la STM.
PASCAL RENAUD, dir. d'études
Société de transport de Montréal
- C'est un bus qui est
silencieux, c'est un bus qui a
une belle douceur de roulement.
C'est des bus climatisés.
On met environ trois heures pour
le recharger. C'est des bus qui
ont une autonomie d'environ
250 kilomètres, donc on peut
très bien l'assigner sur des
routes, pointe AM, pointe PM
pour faire les sorties du matin
et les sorties l'après-midi sans
problème et revenir au garage
pour la recharge
- On ne verra donc pas, dans
l'avenir, une multiplication des
bornes de recharge pour autobus
dans les rues de Montréal.
Les opérations se feront
dans les garages de la STM,
comme celui de Stinson.
- Ce qu'on a ici, c'est
12 chargeurs de 150 kw qui
permettent de recharger nos bus.
- 65 kilomètres de câbles fixés
au plafond transportent
l'électricité jusqu'aux
44 équipements de recharge du
garage.
Mais si, pour l'instant, la
capacité électrique du centre
Stinson est suffisante, elle ne
le sera plus dans les prochaines
années.
- Je vous annonce donc que
le Québec va acheter pour
5 milliards, 5 milliards
d'autobus urbains!
- Lors de la COP26, en Écosse,
François Legault a annoncé son
intention d'électrifier 55 %
autobus québécois d'ici 2030.
Pour respecter cette cible,
la STM, qui n'a que 42 bus
électriques aujourd'hui, devrait
donc en avoir 1072 dans 8 ans.
- C'est réaliste. On est
confiant est colossal,
mais on est confiants.
Nos équipes travaillent fort
pour y a qui est
important pour nous, c'est
d'avoir un engagement ferme de
notre gouvernement, donc de nos
partenaires, qui vont permettre
de financer l'électrification.
- Déjà endettée avec la
pandémie, la STM prévoit qu'il
faudra investir 4,7 milliards $
sur 10 ans pour son
électrification.
La première phase de 670
millions est déjà en route et
servira à adapter 4 de ses 9
garages, dont celui de Stinson.
- Ça va être de revoir nos
infrastructures pour amener
la puissance nécessaire
pour recharger un parc
de 350 autobus, installer
les équipement de distribution,
installer les chargeurs,
donc ça va demander des travaux
supplémentaires et des
agrandissements dans nos
garages.
- Il faudra aussi acheter les
autobus. Les nouveaux ont coûté
1,2 millions $ chacun, soit
400 000 de plus qu'un autobus
hybride. Québec s'engage à payer
environ les deux tiers de
la facture d'électrification
des Sociétés de transport.
- Nos prochains bus électriq
qu'on va acheter, c'est à partir
de 2025, donc on a un programme
de remplacement qui va
s'échelonner sur une durée
de 16 ans. On peut penser
que d'ici en 2040-2041, on va
pouvoir remplacer le parc
complet de bus hyb
de la STM.
- Il faudra aussi former tout
le personnel, dont les
chauffeurs. Nous avons roulé
dans un des nouveaux autobus
avec Joseph Tamé, qui participe
au projet pilote depuis 3 mois.
- Est-ce que c'est le fun à
conduire?
JOSEPH TAMÉ, chauffeur, STM
- Très le fun à conduire.
C'est quelque chose de nouveau,
c'est de la technologie,
c'est quelque chose qu'on va
pouvoir travailler avec,
c'est écologique, alors ça fait
une grosse différence.
- Quand tous les chauffeurs
comme Joseph rouleront
électrique, la STM estime que
112 000 tonnes de GES en moins
seront envoyées dans
l'atmosphère chaque année,
soit l'équivalent de retirer
28 000 voitures à